[Music]
the question is in the book let's play
docker you can make your own
determination whether or not you have a
fracture somebody love has a fracture by
putting a tuning fork on there you can
go into any drugstore and get our a
bookstore at the medical school
or
the biology school at the university get
a little c tuning fork tap it and while
it's still vibrating touch it to a
fracture you think is a fracture and if
it is real painful you know it's a
fracture you can also do the same thing
with the tooth if the fracture of the
tooth is down into the root you will
jump out of your seat okay this
gentleman's got a low platelet count
because the doctors say his antibodies
are attacking his own
platelets do you take vitamins and
minerals
what do you take he just started okay
she's honest he just started
okay this guy just started taking
vitamins and minerals so what i want you
to do is take dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula for two months and then go back
and have another platelet count the
reason why i say that is your bone
marrow that produces platelets that
produces white blood cells and red blood
cells requires 90 nutrients to do that
the first thing they're going to want to
do is give you some chemotherapy
we're going to want to give you
chemotherapy or prednisone or something
to calm that down try dr wallick's piggy
arthritis formula for two months first
and go back and get that checked anybody
else
yes in the blue
uh the dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula is written in the book let's
play doctor but it's it's under
arthritis and osteoporosis but instead
of saying
gelatin it says chondroitin sulfate
because you can't use brand names in a
book
fibromyalgia yes this is actually a
disease that we eliminated in sheep in
1957 called stiff lamb disease and sheep
anybody hear ray sheep
anybody raise sheep do you ever hear a
stimplam disease
yup do you know how to prevent it and
cure it
okay with a trace mineral called
selenium
selenium it's a kind of an anal onset
muscular dystrophy
it's a disease that was not around 10 15
years ago if it was there weren't nobody
knew how to diagnose it and the reason
why we have so much of it today suddenly
is because we have a large intake as a
people of vegetable oils things that
margarine and cooking oils and salad
dressings and when you have a deficiency
of selenium if you take in large dose of
vegetable oils it aggravates that
deficiency and you get what's called
fibromyalgia so if you take
dr wallach's pig arthritis formula has
lots of colloidal selenium in it and
give up all fried foods
and all vegetable oil salad dressings
cooking oils and margarine
see what happens in 90 days you'll be a
happy camper yes sir
hemochromatosis iron storage disease all
kinds of stuff like that this is the big
rage now don't supplement with iron you
know they tell you but i hope you don't
listen to them because most people who
have hemochromatosis or iron storage
disease have never ever supplemented
with iron
right
okay
now
the reason why people get
hemochromatosis and iron storage disease
is not because you take in too much iron
you eat too much red meat or
supplement with irons because you have a
copper deficiency
you have a copper deficiency you take
all 90 nutrients including
colloidal copper the hemochromocotosis
and iron storage disease will go away
because you're giving that missing piece
to the chemical reactions
back here
migraines are always food allergies what
you want to do for one month keep a
little book a little spiral notebook in
your pocket or purse and every time you
put food in your mouth put great detail
the time of which you ate it and what
you ate the pizza don't just say pizza
you got to say everything that's on the
pizza and then write down the times at
which migraine headaches appear don't
look at the results don't try to
interpret it until the end of a full
month that goes by then go back with a
yellow highlighter highlight all the
places where you had a migraine headache
and then go to the snack or the meal
just before that and you'll find a
common thread you eliminate that food
out of your diet you won't have
migraines anymore yes sir
asthma is a
deficiency of two minerals and essential
fatty acid the two minerals are
magnesium and manganese and essential
fatty acids which you can get from
either flaxseed all capsules that's what
i personally take are fish oil yes
okay after a complete hysterectomy no
ovaries use you do not need estrogen
replacement
you give your adrenal glands in your
liver all the raw materials they need
okay which is the 90 nutrients plus
cholesterol you'll produce enough
estrogen so you won't get any of the
side effects or if you do to be minimal
minimal uh side effects of this instant
menopause you get from a hysterectomy
shogun's disease okay dry mouth no tears
or little tears always this is due to a
vitamin a deficiency
always is due to vitamin a deficiency if
you're not supplementing with vitamin a
do you take multivitamin minerals
no okay it's a vitamin a deficiency i
don't have to say anymore
okay do you have an adrenal problem
oh a friend okay yeah they have an
adrenal gland problem they can have a
tumor there they might have a long term
series of chrome of
prednisone or cortisone treatments
okay
okay oh they had a bad reaction to it
might have been cushing's disease okay
and of course so what you want to do is
give them all 90 nutrients give them dr
wallach's pig arthritis formula whether
it's the adrenal glands or the testicles
the ovaries the pituitary the thyroid
something's missing there when those
things happen
dry skin looks like he's been rolled in
rice krispies yeah okay
yeah this is called dry eczema sometimes
it'll crack and bleed or ooze
yeah ugly okay now this is due to an
essential fatty acid deficiency
he needs the chicken skin not fried but
roasted baked or broiled chicken skin he
also needs to eat fish three or four
times a week not fried but roasted baked
steamed
to get the essential fatty acids he can
also take the flaxseed all capsules with
breakfast lunch and supper how old is
the kid
11. okay he's almost an adult and then
he could take dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula but also you want to get him off
of all wheat because he probably has
what's called celiac disease the wheat
gluten prevents the absorption of
essential fatty acids and you start
seeing this eczema all over the body yes
numbness in the feet could be due to
dozens of things it could be for
instance due to b12 deficiency it could
be due to neuropathy from a uncontrolled
diabetes it could be due to spinal
stenosis
which is caused by
excuse me a osteoporosis where the
vertebrae try to get stronger by growing
big with connective tissue because they
don't have enough minerals and it begins
to squish on the spinal nerves in the
spinal cord so it could be many things
you have to find out first what it is
and the book let's play doctor will tell
you how to do that
okay vitiligo is a loss of skin color
and is due to a deficiency of folic acid
and paba p-a-b-a and you can actually
take mega doses of those things and take
all 90 essential nutrients and your skin
color will come back next
i'm sorry
oh macular degeneration okay this is
where you get a degeneration of the
retina of the eye
okay
and
this is due to a deficiency of three
nutrients number one it's a deficiency
of a special amino acid which you have
to go to a health food store and get
this amino acid in 500 milligram
capsules it's called taurine
t-a-u-r-i-n-e
then
selenium and vitamin e you also have to
give up vegetable oils and salad
dressing and all fried foods
hay fever
okay miserable hay fever you may not be
able to totally get rid of it but if you
want to reduce it significantly what you
have to do is go on a rotation diet in
other words don't eat the same food
every day don't eat bread every day
don't eat hamburgers every day don't eat
eggs every day you have to eat foods
once every third day or once every fifth
day it's called a rotation diet and you
want to take some
digestive aids to kind of reduce all the
possibility of undigested proteins and
things like that
causing
stress on your immune system then you
want to make sure the individual takes
all 90 nutrients so their immune system
is up to where they can defend
themselves it's a big process
and but is it worth it yes
parasites you talk about worms or little
one-celled things
all parasites okay well it's a big field
uh the one celled things of course uh if
you take all 90 nutrients and you take
some oxygen the food grade hydrogen
peroxide and drops in distilled water
very frequently just oxygenating the
bowels is enough to kill out the one
cell parasites
the worms
what i like to do if you want to use
herbs there's things like wormwood and
black walnut hulls
ground up you can get in capsules and
health food stores that works pretty
good what i used to do with my kids
is i'd give them sheepwarmer
okay parkinson's disease i'll cover
three diseases at one time here
ms multiple sclerosis als lou gehrig's
disease and parkinson's disease they all
seem to have the same cause a mercury
poisoning causing damage to the brain
causing damage to the cholesterol part
of the brain the myelin
coating of the nerve trunks
there's two ways that you can get
mercury number one you get it from your
mercury amalgam fillings and so you want
to get all the mercury fillings out the
other way is the most common uh trade
that gets uh parkinson's disease is
farmers because they they deal with
mercury coated seed grains to prevent
the molding of the seeds in the soil
farmers yeah
and so what you want to do is get all
the mercury out of your life and then
you want to take um dr wallace's pig
arthritis formula because it has
colloidal selenium in it which is a
specific antidote to dump stored mercury
in your brain liver and other tissues
and lastly get a hold of a book called
dr swank's diet for ms and it's good for
parkinson's disease als and ms yes
okay pernicious anemia is a b12
deficiency is this in a young person or
a senior okay
do you have belching burping and
bloating
yes okay good very honest lady
and now the reason why you have
pernicious anemia or b12 deficiency
anemia and you have belching burping and
bloating they always go together is
because you don't have enough stomach
acid in your stomach and you cannot
absorb b12 without a very acid stomach
diabetes
okay diabetes adult onset diabetes is a
chromium and vanadium deficiency dr
wallick's pig arthritis formula and
another product we have has the chelated
form of chromium and vanadium i've
literally seen thousands of people who
had adult onset diabetes including my
own 82 year old father-in-law who'd been
on insulin for 20 years over a period of
three and a half months actually been
able to wean off of his insulin just
something by taking in the colloidal
form of chromium and vanadium
it's just very simple and of course
diabetics are trained to monitor their
blood sugar they're trained to monitor
and
take care of their insulin requirements
on a day-to-day basis so you're in a
very good position if for instance you
wake up in the morning and your blood
sugar is 50 would you take insulin that
morning no obviously not and so as your
blood sugar comes down you can begin to
slowly wean off of your insulin and
reduce your insulin and you're trained
how to do that
manic depression okay manic depression
depression bipolar disease hyperactivity
add adhd
all of these kind of emotional things
have the same approach nutritionally
number one you want to give up all sugar
natural and processed no apple juice no
grape juice
no honey no molasses no processed sugar
no donuts no candy no sugar frosted
flakes you know nothing like that and
even hot dogs have
corn syrup in them you got to read
labels and exclude all that then you
want to take dr walt's pig arthritis
formula because it has lithium chromium
and vanadium in it oh okay
childhood diabetes okay
childhood or juvenile onset diabetes
all the research shows that these
individuals are allergic to dairy and
the beta cells in the eyelids of
langerhan that produce the insulin the
cell membrane
is in fact
uh has a similar amino acid sequence as
does milk protein and so almost always
these people are allergic to milk and so
you got to get them off of dairy get
this this uh
antibody thing that's going crazy
against milk to disappear so it won't
attack their own beta cells and then of
course they need to take chromium and
vanadium and there's no reason why these
kids can't live to be a hundred if they
take chromium and vanadium and dr
wallach's pig arthritis farm is a good
source and get off of dairy they have to
be good they have to have a sugar-free
diet and do the diabetic thing and if
they're good there's no reason why they
can't live to be 100 yes the purple
pulmonary hypertension
okay usually these are people with
some kind of obstructive disease
okay uh you have chronic pulmonary
obstructive disease of one kind or
asthma
emphysema and of course as a result the
pressure
blood pressure goes up as a result of
the chronic lung disease correct
okay i'm sorry
yeah heart and lung disease you have
cystic fibrosis
no
okay well again i would treat yourself
like asthma nutritionally what i would
do is take dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula for the manganese and magnesium
i would take essential fatty acids i
would take three of those thousand
milligram capsules for breakfast lunch
and supper for a total of nine a day
give up all sugar give up all caffeine
absolutely no fats or vegetable oils in
your diet except for the essential fatty
acids which you're going to supplement
with no salad dressing no deep fried
foods
absolutely none
yes ma'am
neurofibromatosis elephant man disease
i don't know
enough about that when it comes to
nutrition but if i had the disease or
had a patient with it when i've never
had a patient with it and i've always
wanted to try this was use dr wallach's
pig arthritis formula with it because
really what it looks like to me is a
form of paget's disease especially with
all the bone deformities and the skull
and the large bones of the arms and so
forth it looks like paget's disease a
form of pages disease which occurs
mostly in males
and i would like to try dr wallach's pig
arthritis formula for three months you
have everything to gain nothing to lose
by trying it
a low temperature is that wilson
syndrome
okay nothing else just low temperature
okay that's usually thyroid gland stuff
if you want to get your temperature up
take some cayenne pepper it'll rise
right up
quickly but also take the 90 nutrients
which will stimulate the thyroid gland
and get yourself going but do do the
half a teaspoon of cayenne and then work
up to a teaspoon a day in hot water yes
in the red
okay what's the difference between
minerals medicinal herbs this is a very
good question
medicinal herbs are plant medicines they
drive your body to do things if you're
constipated it'll loosen you up if
you're a diarrhea it'll tighten you up
if you have high blood pressure you can
bring it down but you get off the herbs
the blood pressure goes back up doesn't
cure anything they're medicines that
make your body do things
minerals actually
fit into the biochemistry of each cell
in your body and are required to prevent
diseases herbs are not required to
prevent diseases herbs will work better
if you take minerals because your body
can more uniformly respond to these
herbs or acupuncture or chiropractic or
whatever it might be
okay psoriasis up until a year ago i
didn't have a good answer for that
but
here's what i've learned number one they
need to take dr wallick's pig arthritis
formula twice a day add in the
flaxseed oil capsules to make sure they
get all 90 nutrients and that'll improve
psoriasis about 40 percent
the scales will drop off the skin will
get nice and pink underneath instead of
fiery red and all cracked and bleeding
and everything
and then
what you want to do is puree a big
bermuda onion skin it and puree it
put it in a bowl then puree a big
cucumber skin and puree it
take the bermuda onion puree smear it on
the psoriasis lesions and sores and
it'll sting like you put alcohol in a
cup in about five minutes it'll stop
stinging you wipe it off don't wash it
off wipe it off put on the
pureed cucumber that will sting and when
that stops stinging wipe that off put on
a good collagen cream leave it on there
all day and then two hours before you go
to bed go through the onion and the
cucumber thing again and sleep all night
with the collagen cream on and in about
a month or two the psoriasis will go
away you have to keep repeating that
treatment about every couple of months
but it'll keep it away every time you
see a little dime-sized spot show up you
hit it again with that treatment
chronic cold sores herpes simplex virus
again if you have things like jock itch
and vaginal yeast infections you have
fungus in your toenails athlete's foot
herpes those kinds of things it means
your own immune system doesn't have
enough strength to keep all these little
things away from you which most people
are able to do and so you want to take
dr wallick's pig arthritis formula twice
a day give your immune system all the
nutrients it needs
okay prostate okay let's start out first
with prostate
um
80 of all men over the age of 50 in
america having a large prostate whenever
you get a statistic like that it tells
you it's a nutritional problem they're
missing minerals okay
you get them on dr wallick's pig
arthritis farm and we have another one
which has a herb in it called
saw palmetto which will actually shrink
the the prostate gland
and then
prostate cancer in addition to taking
all 90 nutrients get your immune system
up you also want to take some shark
cartilage
okay which prevents the spread of the
prostate cancer into the bone one of the
interesting things if the person is over
60 years of age all of these statistics
show that they should not get
chemotherapy or radiation
because they will live
12 to 15 years if they're over 60 with a
prostate cancer
and of course if you get uh chemotherapy
or radiation the average lifespan is
five years
and so you're very sane not to take it
oh you're still coughing yes okay two
years ago you had walking pneumonia and
you're still coughing okay well you
might have some uh scar tissue or damage
or you might have chronic bronchitis
okay all kinds of possibilities in there
and did you plow fields and work in dust
and chemicals and things like that
what'd you do for a living
no no what did you do for a living
there's no hope
okay basically what you want to do is
take dr wallach's pig arthritis formula
and be sure to take the um uh essential
fatty acids in the form of flaxseed all
you also want to look at taking the
oxygen supplement
okay post-polio syndrome kind of thing
yeah okay
hum
yeah but did he get polio vaccine
he's shaking his head yes okay so it
could have been from that now the thing
to do the best thing he can do for
himself is to take dr wallach's pig
arthritis formula twice a day and the
reason why i say that so much they're
saying this wallet is selling snake oil
you know every time if somebody asks for
a different disease how to take dr
wellick's pig arthritis formula it
contains 87 nutrients remember there's
10 diseases for each nutrient eight 10
times 87 is 870 different diseases are
going to be covered by that formula
endometriosis you're not going to fix
that with nutrition but there is a
posterior pituitary hormone which you
can get from the ob it's a prescription
it's called luperon
endometriosis and also the fibroids in
the uterus you can shrink those things
with the luperon and you can get them
down from big big you know the size of a
grapefruit down the side of your little
fingernail and you can go in through
your belly button with a endoscopic
tools and snip that thing off of there
without having to get a hysterectomy
neurological problems sure b1 deficiency
b12 deficiency uh calcium deficiency
uh copper deficiency there's all kinds
of them so the best thing to do don't
try and pick one out take them all
get off of all sugar
gout okay gal you want to stay on the
diet no beans no seafood no lentils that
kind of stuff no wine no beer no yeast
and if you do that faithfully you won't
get very many flare-ups during the year
maybe none but if you do get a flare-up
there's two things you can do number one
there's an herb called meadow saffron it
does the source a natural source of
colchison which is the drug of choice by
medical doctors for
gout you can also of course
take a vitamin called folic acid you
want to take large amounts of this 20
milligrams a day during a flare-up and
it drives your liver to gobble up all
that uric acid
okay repeated miscarriages almost always
is due to a
deficiency disease of something it could
be selenium could be zinc could be
copper could be vitamin a it could be
vitamin e and of course i always say
that i've gotten more women pregnant
than any other man on earth because i've
literally had thousands and thousands of
cases like this where women are
infertile they get going they get a
miscarriage somewhere along the line
and what they do is take dr wallick's
pig arthritis formula faithfully my own
daughter is a great story
she's 34 years old and married 12 years
and they tried and tried and tried and
couldn't get a pregnancy and against my
best
advice to her she and her husband went
around the world to all the experts of
europe and
france and england and went to the mayo
clinic hold the mayo don't even go there
you know and um uh after 12 years of
searching and trying they were
told that she was stir hopelessly
sterile couldn't have any children
and she came to me in tears it looks
like we're going to have to adopt a baby
and i said well look why don't you try
dr wallace pig arthritis formula for six
months before you make that decision
three months later she calls me she says
dad i'm pregnant i said why didn't you
do that before you spent 150 000 she
says well they were experts
yes ma'am
hypoglycemia low blood sugar is the
first symptom of diabetes it's on the
same curve it's the earliest symptoms of
diabetes if you don't deal with low
blood sugar if you just try to deal with
it by regulating your diet and avoiding
sugar you're going to get diabetes it
sure as god made little green apples and
so what you want to do in addition to
not taking in any sugar doctors say oh
you get low blood sugar eat a candy bar
that's the wrong thing to do what you
want to do is eat about five or six
small meals a day i've had people with
such bad low blood sugar hypoglycemia i
had them just go to a mcdonald's and get
nothing but the hamburger patty they'd
get a dozen of them at a time and they
would eat two hamburger patties and an
hour later they need another two
hamburger patties two hours later
another two hamburger patties but you
also want to take dr wallick's pig
arthritis formula because it's got the
chromium and vanadium in it that'll take
care of this um uh body's inability to
deal with blood sugar regulate things
and get you out of trouble yes ma'am
okay muscle spasms in the back after an
accident doesn't matter if a horse has
jumped on you a car accident plane
accident or you just whacked him around
a little bit
you want to get him on dr wallach's pig
arthritis formula get him on all those
minerals
okay that's that's what's missing
okay another one real quick
graves disease thyroid problem
hyperactive thyroid right again what
happens to your thyroid when you have an
iodine deficiency it gets big it's
overactive trying to compensate for this
lack of iodine
there's two things that can happen
number one you can be deficient in 90
nutrients any one of which can cause
graves disease your thyroid gets big
trying to compensate for something
missing
number two
people who eat too many what's called
goitrogens nitrates for instance which
are in bacon ham lunch meats
10 certain foods such as broccoli and
brussels sprouts and cabbage those are
goitrogens and they will actually cause
the hyperactivity of the thyroid gland
so you have to get off of all those
glycogens many of them which are listed
in the book
let's play doctor and take all 90
nutrients
basically for circulation
uh you want to you can do the cayenne
pepper thing it was just cold hands at
night it may be just a thyroid thing and
something's missing okay whether it's
tyrosine amino acid or if it's zinc or
if it's copper or if it's iodine you
don't know without thousands of dollars
worth of tests i always get people
asking me this with doc how do i know
which one it is i said will you give me
two thousand dollars i'll run all the
tests and i'll tell you which one it is
but why don't you try dr wallace pig
arthritis formula for you know 50 bucks
a month for two months before you make
that decision
and usually 97 of these things go away
if you just take in all 90 nutrients
okay
mononucleosis or epstein-barr virus of
course one of the reasons why people get
that is they don't have enough
of the nutrients to keep their immune
system
tough enough to keep those viruses away
and normally when people get
epstein-barber she should be sick two
weeks but when you have this year-long
mononuclease infectious mononuclease
thing
it's because your immune system isn't
strong enough to throw it out did you
get infectious mononucleosis after
chemotherapy
with the leukemia yeah
okay so it's all kind of twisted in
together leukemia is caused by a
chemical carcinogen whether it's in the
drinking water from a deep well or
something chemical in the air or the
food who knows it's a carcinogen some
chemical you've got sometime
five or ten years before you're
diagnosed which causes the leukemia and
so what you got to do is clean up your
life you have to drink filtered
or
distilled water to get all the chemicals
out of your drinking water you should
eat organically grown food as much as
possible to get the chemicals
out of your food you should filter the
air in your house and your workplace and
your car get all the chemicals out of
the air and you need to take all 90
nutrients and watch what happens
yes sir
okay
okay if you have a blockage whether it's
in the coronary artery or a carotid
artery blockage of it when it gets so
bad a lot of times they won't do surgery
on it because they're afraid to tamper
with it because it's gonna break a clot
loose or something and they'll say well
just you know you're you're going to do
what you're going to do because we're
not going to do surgery on it or maybe
you're like me and you don't like
surgery what i would do is the
intravenous
chelation therapy get some of the edta
and roto-root out those arteries with
intravenous chelation and i would do
that first it's a non-invasive thing and
it nobody's ever been killed with it and
it works like a charm
well that's sugar it's just chocolate
covered sugar okay
yeah
okay well you want to get rid of your
problem what you want to do see now amy
vanderbilt said that women are not
supposed to sweat
you know it's only horses horses sweat
men perspire and women glow right unless
you're a teacher or coach and so what
you want to do is take in all 90
essential nutrients take in the pig
arthritis formula twice a day including
the gelatin especially since you're
doing impact stuff with aerobics or gym
or whatever it might be
and um
every time you crave chocolate take in
an extra ounce of those minerals
maybe 10 times a day for the first month
and then when you super saturate your
body with minerals the craving for
chocolate will go away you want to take
those minerals with an extra ounce of
the calcium enriched orange juice
because if you try and take them
straight they'll shrink wrap your lips
over your mouth they're very astringent
yeah
okay the normal cholesterol should be
between 220 and 270. you want to be
between 220 and 270. let me give you a
couple of examples real quick here
think about eskimos above the arctic
circle
95 of their diet or more sometimes 97 of
their diet during the wintertime is
nothing more than red meat and blubber
whale meat and whale blubber walrus meat
walrus blubber seal meat seal blubber
bare meat and bear fat they don't eat
organically grown broccoli and they
don't juice or anything like that and
they're legendary for not getting
cardiovascular disease and the reason is
they eat salmon every day either fresh
during the salmon season or maybe
salted smoked or dried the rest of the
year and when they eat the salmon they
get what's called omega-3 oils the
essential fatty acids which keep their
cardiovascular system healthy
so you can eat all the meat you want if
you take in all 90 essential nutrients
and you won't get cardiovascular disease
remember those 400
people over age 100 in colorado just two
weeks ago when they did the survey on
them the only common denominator was
they were heavy meat eaters
eating meat and cholesterol will not
cause cardiovascular disease that's
cocka there's other problems
yes sir
colitis there's all kinds of colitis
things like
oh let's see irritable bowel syndrome
ulcerative colitis
crohn's disease almost always these are
due to a sensitivity to wheat gluten and
these are various forms of celiac
disease in the colon
of course medical doctors want to do the
cortisone and then surgery and that sort
of thing and so you're better off trying
to give up wheat and take all 90
essential nutrients the reason why you
want to give up wheat is because when
people have celiac disease they're
always sensitive to wheat gluten and one
of the manifestations or one of the
symptoms of celiac disease is colitis of
various types yes ma'am
okay
the colloidal minerals the pig arthritis
formula can certainly prevent kidney
stones because it prevents this loss of
calcium from your bones
now the kidney stones you already have
what you want to do is acidify your
urine if they're not causing
excruciating pain if you acidify your
urine it'll slowly etch those stones
away it may take a year or two or three
years
yeah but they they can go away you have
to acidify your urine drink
eight ounces of unsweetened cranberry
juice twice a day
asthma well asthma and emphysema are two
different things
asthma is due to a deficiency of three
nutrients magnesium manganese and the
essential fatty acids so you want to try
dr alex pig arthritis formula in evening
primrose oil or flaxseed oil salmon oil
emphysema you got to give up smoking or
wear a mask when you're around dust take
all 90 essential nutrients give up fried
foods
and
you might get five percent better which
is better than nothing it's not going to
progress
uh the emphysema asthma you can get
possibly 100 better
okay
his father is a kidney transplant
patient with cirrhosis of the liver
well there's lots of eighty-five percent
of the people with liver cirrhosis have
nothing to do with drinking it's almost
always a deficiency of selenium copper
things like this and doctors say it may
have been a virus but the odds are it
really isn't it's probably a mineral
deficiency you see these little kids
were born with cirrhosis of liver and
they need a liver transplant when their
newborn kids are a couple years old
that's not because they're drinking it's
because they have a deficiency of
selenium and copper
so what do you do about it well you want
to take in all 90 essential nutrients
his new kidney and his liver needs uh
nutrition
and
it's not going to it's not going to
cause problem with the medication we
have every person with every kind of
medication you can think of and has been
using this since 1926 there's not been
any problems yes
dialysis well again dialysis is not
selective it doesn't just take out the
bad stuff it takes out the good stuff
too and usually when you're on dialysis
for a couple years you get osteoporosis
and arthritis high blood pressure and
diabetes and all kinds of stuff if you
don't already have diabetes and so
people who get on the pig arthritis
formula
very quickly within 72 hours they feel
as this energy and their bones start
getting stronger in rebuilding the only
thing that might be a concern
is the
gelatin which is a high nitrogen source
and so you want to ask the urologist
about that
tinnitus ringing in the ears tinnitus
ringing in the ears is there any vertigo
with it or imbalance problems okay the
reason why i asked that
meniere's disease or ringing in the ears
it can be due to several problems high
blood pressure certain medications can
cause it if you eliminate those
possibilities 95 of all ringing in the
ears is caused by what i call wallex
vertigo i call it walleyes vertigo
because i figured out what causes it
nobody else they describe it nobody
knows how to help it and basically again
it's caused by osteoporosis as your
bones try to get stronger when they
don't have enough minerals in them they
enlarge by generating connective tissue
and when the eighth cranial nerve comes
from the brain through a little quarter
inch canal in the skull into the inner
ear it has two branches one is the
auditory branch which controls hearing
and noise the vestibular branch controls
balance if this connective tissue
crushes the
auditory branch you get ringing in the
ears if it crushes the vestibular branch
you get imbalance problems balance
problems with vertigo
you can crush them both or one or the
other so what you want to do is get on
the pig arthritis formula reverse
reverse that
connective tissue growth and release
that pressure on the nerve and see what
happens i've had literally hundreds of
people hundreds of people who have
gotten over this problem
tic delaroo yeah that's a trigenical
nerve neuralgia
and
bell's palsy which is the seventh
cranial nerve trigeminal nerve is the
fifth cranial nerve vertigo and
meniere's disease which is ringing in
the ears is the eighth cranial nerve and
spinal stenosis those four diseases are
related they're all due to
fibro
osteodystrophy which is a form of
osteoporosis the latch of fibrous
connective scar tissue and it squeezes
down on those nerves and causes the
symptom based on which nerve it is the
fifth cranial nerve you get a lot of
pain on the side of the head and neck
and shoulder and you kind of touch them
and they just go bonkers because it's
very painful you get on the pig
arthritis formula and rebuild that bone
shrink that scar tissue and relieve that
nerve of the pressure they get better
yes sir
i recommend all 90 essential nutrients
including vitamin e
tubular aggregate myopathy
okay you're talking about a
muscle disease okay
again they can give it all the fancy
names they want is this an adult or a
child
adult
and this just came on them as an adult
yeah okay okay so what you do is you
give up all fried foods and all
vegetable oils take in all 90 essential
nutrients do the pig arthritis formula
with the calcium enriched orange juice
the willamette valley gelatin the
colloidal minerals and the colloidal
multiple and
do it for 60 90 days twice a day and see
what happens
you'll be a happy camper
can too many vitamins and minerals be
bad for you
well let me answer you in two ways i'll
answer you specifically but first i'll
answer you in general
300 000 americans are killed each year
in hospitals loans result of medical
negligence if you look at all the people
who were injured and infected and killed
outside and inside the hospital there's
a total of five million casualties
inflicted on american people every year
by the medical profession not a single
person has been killed or wounded by a
vitamin or mineral in america maybe a
couple of kids who are two years old eat
a whole bottle of vitamin a you know
they're going to get some liver problems
they can flush them out and things and
they'll be okay but as far as even
taking five times the rda nothing bad is
going to happen to you and it's doctors
who usually tell people you got to watch
it don't take vitamins and minerals
because you could overdose and they kill
and poison you know right left and
center so you don't have to worry about
it in general specifically if you say
can you kill somebody with a vitamin
i suppose if you froze it and hit them
in the head with it you might
yes sir
varicose veins
copper deficiency
back when i started doing this kind of
stuff many many years ago
we get people on the colloidal products
and and uh dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula people would be taking the pig
arthritis for a meal for arthritis and
they say doc you know this is wonder
stuff my my varicose veins got better
and so i started learning and i looked
it up why is because of the copper
colloidal copper that's in the pig
arthritis from it
a kombucha tea sure it's not actually a
mushroom is usually called a kombucha
mushroom it's a yeast or bacterial
colony as grown in sugar water and of
course you can't depend on it for
minerals because yeast cannot generate
minerals it's kind of a fun food it
generates maybe some enzymes and things
but that's about it
it's a great fun tea it's a good herbal
tea but it doesn't have any real
nutrition in it from the standpoint of
of minerals
channel blockers do you know the calcium
channel blockers increase your risk of
death by 60 percent
in the newspaper i don't know if your
doctor got you off any doctor that
leaves a patient on a calcium channel
blocker is malignant dumb and borders on
malpractice increases your risk of a
heart attack by 60 percent
okay crohn's disease irritable bowel
syndrome or ulcerative colitis is
actually due to a sensitivity to wheat
gluten and so if you want to deal with
crohn's disease irritable bowel syndrome
or ulcer ulcerative colitis you have to
give up wheat gluten there's actually
gluten-free flours and breads or you
just have to give up wheat 90 of the
people on earth don't eat wheat so it's
not a big crime you eat wheat or rice
and oats and other things corn uh but
also you want to take dr walt's pig
arthritis farm and make sure you get all
90 nutrients and repair yourself
glaucoma
in my experience glaucoma is caused by
muscular dystrophy the eye muscles one
muscle being stronger than the other and
it kind of torques the eye and twists it
so that it can't drain properly from the
fluid that's constantly produced in the
inside and you build up pressure and the
only way to deal with this other than
you know obviously you need to put drops
in the eyes to keep the pressure down
and you don't want a cold turkey you
don't even stop those things until the
doctor tells you your pressure is normal
because you can go blind very quickly
but what you want to do is give up all
things that are going to contribute to
that muscular dystrophy the eye muscles
things like vegetable oils cooking oils
salad dressings things like margarines
and then
you want to be sure to take all 90
nutrients including the selenium
methionine the amino acid and vitamin e
okay in the red
impotency well you don't have to worry
about that do you
no you're on the other end yeah okay now
usually
if this is due to a guy who's on some
kind of medication for high blood
pressure or something like that what you
want to do is get him on dr wallick's
pig arthritis formula fix the high blood
pressure with calcium so he can get off
the medication
then he'll stand right back up
okay
well it certainly can't hurt her okay
can't hurt her has gallium in it and
things like that
but if you're really looking for some
alternative things to do for brain
cancer i'd consider one of these dozens
of alternative clinics in in mexico
because you need some help here you need
to do something real drastic you need to
do something really drastic if you're
gonna fix brain cancer with anything i
mean it's tough okay and so you're gonna
have to jump in very quickly and make a
decision and i can help you i guess give
us your name and phone number we'll give
you some addresses and phone numbers
lymphedema was there any surgery like
mammoectomy or anything like that
mastectomy
no okay just you have edema of the legs
or ankles
legs okay
have you been on any medication for that
not really okay one other question
at the time you got this were you taking
any vitamins and minerals no
okay
on one leg okay well that's kind of
interesting left leg or right leg
huh
left leg okay what it could be is
especially if you're constipated or have
hemorrhoids or something like that you
can interfere with the blood return and
the lymph return from that leg because
the colon and everything kind of sits on
that side
and so if you're constipated and have
you know yourself full of bricks in
there it plugs the return
if not you may just have something
structural or the ring that that vein
comes through might be if it's just one
leg then it's a different problem it's a
mechanical problem
if you can't take orange juice put it in
water but then you got to take some
extra calcium to make up the difference
rectal bleeding
oh retinol in the eye bleeding okay
again
okay get an attachment of the retina you
get bleeding behind it what not
again you're missing something okay
because normally the retinas stay
plastered where they're supposed to be
when you start getting a break down here
it can be anything from a copper
deficiency if i could look in your eyes
i could almost tell you because when you
have a copper deficiency the arteries of
your eyes instead of being straight they
get all wiggly like an old river because
the elastic fibers are breaking down
just like on the waistband of your
underwear when they drop down around
your knees so you're missing something i
can tell from here you have lovely gray
hair right
yeah this is due to a copper deficiency
that's probably it in the purple
multiple sclerosis also lou gehrig's
disease als parkinson's disease are all
kind of related just different parts of
the brain are affected
one of the prevailing theories now is
it's due to a mercury poisoning from
fillings and one of the things you have
to do is get all the fillings out of
your mouth which is the constant source
of mercury poisoning to the brain also
you have to take in relatively large
doses of cholesterol because what's the
part of the brain that goes away
when you have ms
the myelin right the insulating sheath
has 75 by weight pure cholesterol and so
you need cholesterol you don't need to
be on a cholesterol-free diet if you
have ms because you're going to be in
trouble you can't repair something if
you're not giving it the raw materials
then you want to take
90 nutrients dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula yes ma'am
sure
spasmodic torticollis is where you get a
cramping of the neck muscles it's a
calcium deficiency and if you have
osteoporosis to go along with that you
might get permanent curvature of the
cervical vertebra you go to a
chiropractor and he'll kind of
straighten you back up but unless you
take all 90 essential nutrients you
won't get a permanent cure with
chiropractic because it kind of
straightens you up you get a calcium
deficiency again you get it right back
and so you need to give your body the
raw materials to repair the muscles and
the bones yes
interstitial cystitis this is scar
tissue farming in the bladder wall
and
dmso is a very common medical treatment
for that
but usually that's not enough because
what happens is
you don't have enough raw materials to
repair that it's the lack of raw
materials that caused it in the first
place when you have a change of cells
from one type to another it's usually
from a vitamin a or a zinc deficiency
and even if you've been supplementing
with these things you may not have been
absorbing it in the pill farm and so you
want to try dr wallach's pig arthritis
formula and give up all sugar naturally
processed and for sure you want to give
up fried foods and and vegetable salad
dressings and those kind of things way
in the back
tourette's syndrome
this is where kids or adults kind of
shout sometimes or have a tick maybe
and i've seen it in little kids i've
seen it in
people of all ages and the first
experience i had was a little kid up in
denver and his mother said well do you
think this will help my six-year-old
with tourette's i have no idea so we
gave him
just a teaspoon for 20 pounds of body
weight and in a couple of months she
called me and she said you know his
tourette's went away he doesn't have
this nervousness and all this tick and
screaming and everything it just went
away and so she belonged to a support
group and sure enough she told other
people in there and many many of these
kids up into the teenagers they got
better some of them got completely
better some of them got partially better
and so all i can tell you is if is an
adult if you have tourette syndrome
regardless of the degree you have it
because it comes in various severity
you give it a try but you have to do one
other thing give dr wallace pig
arthritis a try but you have to give up
all sugar
natural and processed no apple juice no
grape juice no pepsi no coca-cola no
donuts no pastries no white sugar in
your coffee no sugar frosted flakes etc
etc
oh torn rotor cuff okay
if it's torn to the point where it's
totally separated you're going to need
some surgery to get the two ends
together if it's just kind of frayed
okay and stretched by taking the raw
materials the 90 essential nutrients
including the 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids those muscle
fibers will repair and get tighter but
again if they're totally severed and
torn then you need to surgically put
them back together
okay uric acid kidney stones are
different from the calcium kidney stones
what you have to do is get your liver
being happy burning up the and churning
up the uric acid you need to go on a
gout diet one that's low in beans and
seafood and things like that
beer and wine you want to give up all
those things which produce a lot of uric
acid you want to give your liver all 90
nutrients so that will actually
deactivate the uric acid and get it out
in your urine instead of having it
collect as a kidney stone you have to
give all 90 nutrients to your liver and
one more thing here
and this of course include uh this story
about my uh father-in-law he's 82 years
old but i had to tell my own story first
i guess uh two years ago i don't know
five years ago uh i was bald from my
ears forward and i see a lot of guys in
this room with my hairline this guy on
the pink shirt right here my hairline
looked like him right there right and i
started on these minerals my wife is six
foot tall we always sit in the couch you
know watch tv or we'll go someplace walk
together and she's always rubbing my
head you know kind of like a pet and she
rubs my head and she says you know you
got some stubble coming up in there i
don't know what and so i knew as the
minerals after about a year doing the
minerals and so i doubled it that's when
i went from one time a day to two times
a day and the hair just shot out and so
everything that i have from my ears
forward has grown in since i've been
taking these minerals twice a day
now my 82 year old father-in-law is very
interesting he
visited us from china for four months
couldn't speak english so i couldn't
hypnotize him and he had one of these
walkers because he had terrible
arthritis and osteoporosis and he was
bent over in pain he's a terrible sight
to behold because he's six foot tall
weight over 200 pounds
and he would just groan with pain every
time he'd move
and i wanted to give him dr wallach's
pig arthritis formula twice a day
and my wife being a surgeon literally
jumped in front of him and said no
you'll overdose him he's 82 years old
you can't give it to him twice a day so
he had a family conference and she
reluctantly agreed to let me give it to
him once a day at breakfast
after about 10 days it was sunday i was
getting ready to go to church we came
running down the stairs and i see his
walker laying over on his side in the
kitchen he said oh this old guy's
falling over he's broken his
hip or his back he's died and he's
crawled behind a couch and croaked and
she's going to blame me and the minerals
right and she's six foot tall knows all
this karate stuff so i was nervous i
look under the beds and behind the
couches and in the closets and i
couldn't find him so i'm sitting down
drinking some herbal tea i look out in
the garden and here he is he's out there
doing these tai chi exercises so i go
run upstairs and get my wife i said
honey look at your dad and he hadn't
done that in 15 years
30 days later he was able to even throw
away his cane and he's walking around
the block with me playing with the
little kids and patting the dogs on the
heads and really enjoying himself
30 days before this i mean the guy was
miserable and
debilitated
then in two and a half months
my wife says honey and she gives me that
little musical voice when she wants
something honey can i borrow your blood
pressure cuff and i said well sure
what's the matter with yours and she
says well it's not working five minutes
later she says yours isn't working
either that's because her father's blood
pressure came down into the normal range
because of the colloidal calcium and he
didn't need his blood pressure
medication anymore at three and a half
months his blood sugar came down into
the normal range and he didn't need
insulin he'd been on insulin for 20
years
now when he went back to china after
four months of visiting us he'd let his
hair grow along because on dr wallach's
pig arthritis farm and his hair was
really growing
and before he could get one haircut a
year you know he had all this wispy hair
and now his hair was really growing out
and he got a haircut and the crown of
his head 40 percent of his skull or his
scalp surface the hair had grown back in
jet black typical chinese hair color and
we've been shipping that stuff to him
every two months we shipped him about
four cases and his hair has grown back
in totally jet black all over his head
he looks like he's 52 instead of 82. and
all his buddies say i don't know what
they do in america but you went there
four months you come back you're half
the age you were when you went
and so it's really an amazing thing it
doesn't matter if you're 82 in fact how
many of you saw um
uh
oh gosh what's that tv talk show with
jay leno tonight's show how many of you
saw the tonight show the other night
okay did you see that
anybody
okay well they had a 97 year old lady on
there who was a handwriting expert
she's one of the people who used the dr
wallace's pig arthritis formula i met
her four years ago
when she was 93
and she came in she was kind of like a
wilted rag her daughters brought her in
kind of under the armpits and they kind
of just put in a chair and she
immediately fell asleep put her on dr
wallach's pig arthritis formula three
months later i went back there and gave
a lecture and she walked up the steps
holding onto the rail and tennis shoes
and she sat down 10 minutes later she
was asleep
i went back there six months later and
she's running up the steps in her tennis
shoes and she has all her girlfriends
with her and her chattering and giggling
and now she was on the tonight show the
other night
because she'd just written a book she'd
been wanting to do it for 40 years and
she never had the energy until she was
on dr wallach's pig arthritis formula i
want to thank you all very much god
bless each and every one of you and god
bless america
[Music]
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you for more presentations
and books that go into greater detail go
to
dockwallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose treat
cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program are the express
opinions of joel d wallick bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly regarding any
medical conditions